also in the east valley metro police
just reopened roads that had been closed
off for hours after a police shooting
officers shot a man near a mobile home
park earlier tonight madison kimbrough
spoke with neighbors and now joins us
live in that area with the very latest
details
yeah this happened on pecos and lake
mead right here at sunrise terrace
mobile home park a neighbor reportedly
called police saying there was a man
walking around with a gun once police
arrived that's when things escalated
a scary situation tuesday evening as a
man was shot during a police shooting he
is now in custody a witness called in
stated there was a subject outside with
a firearm initially when police arrived
and approached the man the man quickly
ran off shortly after he raised his gun
to officers and that's when officers
fired the man was taken to the hospital
and suffered non-life-threatening
injuries and no officers were hurt in
the shooting neighbors who were told to
wait before going back home say
shootings are common in this area you
see this on the regular but nothing like
closed down like this or this long you
get used to it you know
since a little kid you know it's the
same thing this is the ninth incident
from metro so far this year and second
police shooting in less than a week last
thursday nhp troopers shot a man near
red rock
and still no details as to why the man
was walking around in that area with a
gun reporting live madison kimbrough
live local now